I don't know if I'll share it with the
podcast guests though he's such a
gourmet so this morning I hit the trails
just to feel my body again for the first
time so it was great really proud of the
writing that I was able to do get it
done on time and get a turn so now
shifting focus podcast happening today
so he's gonna be here pretty soon I'm
gonna try it out make it quick so this
is kale and strawberries free protein
alchemy chlorella courtesy of Sun
phocion our friends at son potion I'm
not paid by any of these companies I'm
not sponsored by them and I don't make
any money off and these are just
products that I'd like to use will acai
powder Moringa with filtered water so I
think we're all set up
usually people underestimate how long it
takes to get here cool man you ready to
rock
I'm ready we're starting dude Rocco
DiSpirito in the house we're doing the
podcast thanks for making the drive up
here manners they develop them in the
term podcasts what the houses is some I
don't know like he's part of yeah I
don't know but it's not a great word I'm
glad that it's finally catching on I
mean I started this five years ago and
no one was way ahead of everyone I was
like you know what I mean still people
are like I heard you have this podcast
but I don't even know like how to listen
to it and I'm like do you have an iphone
yeah exactly see that purple thing you
know it comes with the phone like I've
never I've never touched that I know so
there's still you know a little bit of a
barrier I think but it's change a lot
you know it's change a lot but I think
most of the barriers are gone yeah and
people look forward to them now and they
have their favorites and yeah and it's
cool like now it's become like blogging
everyone's got a podcast yes I know so I
was a little I mean I wasn't like an
early adopter but I definitely started
mine 34 yeah I mean it wasn't cool to
have a podcast when I study fine but
it's been you know it's been amazing it
gives me an opportunity to like okay and
then she'll come to my house or do I get
to hold you hostage calabasas I'm like
done done have you ever been out to this
area so welcome to LA thank you thank
you so much Congrats on the new book
thanks man yeah it's great so you came
across my radar because people were
saying how Rockets got this new book and
he's got all these he's you know
exploring plant-based and it's got all
these plant-based recipes and I was like
wow that's a development like I knew
your general you know
dori your kind of evolution from you
know a more traditional way of cooking
and cuisine and then you know sort of
gaining weight and getting unhealthy and
then I knew that you had become a
triathlete lost all this kind of weight
and had become this kind of spokesperson
or advocate for healthier living but I
didn't realize like that path had kind
of continued and has now led you to dip
your toe and hit the plant-based world
which is pretty cool yessum is exactly
what happened as my personal diet
evolves I'm realizing that you know we
have to move to a gluten-free diet
dairy-free diet you know organic all
these things that I dared not bring up
in the beginning of right journey
because of the beginning when I said
healthy and cookbook everyone thought it
was insane right my publishers were like
you you're the flavor guy you can't do
healthy but that's hospital food right
it's like telling you comedies you can't
do drama Yeah right exactly but we're
all we're all constantly evolving and it
you know and I shake you know I was
reading the introductory introductory
sections in the new book like you're
very frank about that you're like look
this is how I started these are the
books that I wrote and they did very
well this is how I you know this is how
I learned how to cook and that's what I
was sharing and now it changed and you
know I look back on some of those
recipes and I don't eat that way exactly
and I'm sure they're amazing of course
they are you know James Beard
award-winning book flavor yeah how many
to your than 13 but this is 30 now yeah
like I appreciated your acknowledgment
of that evolutionary path and it's
brought you to here and that's talk for
sure yeah I mean you have to keep
changing I have to be dynamic have to
react to what's going on around you as
you fine-tune your personal health
regimen you you're gonna learn that
things will change all the time as you
get older things will change I will
tolerate less and less garbage and the
cleaner you want to eat them the more
you seem to have to get rid of but I
don't like to talk about this in terms
of deprivation getting rid of things
because if you choose healthy it seems
like there's a whole world of indulgence
that's available to you mmm-hmm when you
get rid of all the packaged garbage and
all the you know gluten-containing foods
that are you typically packaged foods
you're you're all of a sudden open up to
this
world of fresh food yeah and that's a
big world of options you know it's like
it's how my grandma grandma ate and it's
the life she provided for us she grew
fruits and vegetables in her garden she
had you know her own chickens and
rabbits and made her own wine made her
own bread preserve her own tomatoes and
I lived that way for a long time but
because of ethnic self-loathing you know
I did that a hundred percent I went to
France to learn how to cook like French
people and lived there for two years and
now realize it was like this is the this
is the best thing that ever happened to
me growing up with all these wonderful
Italian you know these this lifestyle
that is traditional Contadina style
living you know farmer right I'm we're
living we I think that's right like we
tend to think of it as being new but
it's really kind of like tracing us back
to the old like plant-based eating is
very it's peasant food you know at its
core for sure for sure and I like the
idea of approaching it you know having a
perspective of what you're bringing into
your life what you're inviting into your
life and treating that like a new
adventure as opposed to focusing on okay
these are the things we're cutting out
right now because that's what we do as
humans we look at but we look at
deprivation Oh what what if I don't eat
this and how am I gonna live or how am I
gonna enjoy my food and you know for
somebody who is so extraordinarily
skilled in the kitchen to develop an
appreciation for what can be done in
that world I think is very cool because
I think the plant-based world is full of
people who kind of enter it from you
know strictly kind of medical health
perspective or an advocacy perspective
but it's not very many trained chefs you
know they are willing to there's a few
you know we have got the Matthew Kenny's
and those guys yeah he's a planner and I
mentioned him that book yes I know on
the podcast use price it was good great
he's he's done an amazing job of
bringing awareness to this world and
both see ahead of his time yeah I know
and and the results were always kept
there look
yeah yeah I know he's like I'm like
every time I see you I can't believe how
how fight illan yeah and I mean he's
been eating essentially raw forever you
know and these reserves in a vacuum
okay cuz I think he's like fifty three
or four we're now yeah you're 51 yeah 51
yeah I'm 50 I'm about to turn 51 so
we're about the same age yep cool and
we've had kind of similar in very
different ways but kind of similar
journeys through our relationship to
food so so I want to track it back but I
had one final thought on that I also
want to bring up a New Yorker cartoon
did you see the New York cartoon yeah
what was that oh it's two people talking
and and once I said oh hey I want to
stop a podcast today plastered I know so
many podcast now don't even get me
started that's a whole other podcast and
stop doing right joshing podcaster but
ya know I was gonna tell you this quick
story which is do you know Seamus Mullen
yes yes okay so Seamus is a friend you
know yeah he's about on the podcast too
and when I was in New York maybe a year
ago he's like come come down to tertulia
I'll cook you I'll cook you a
plant-based meal I was like great so I
went down there and he made this
incredible multi-course you know delight
of a dinner for a friend of mine and I
and I was amazed and I was like this is
better than almost anything I've ever
had at any vegan restaurant or any other
kind of like plant-based meal ever I'd
like how did you how did you do this and
he said something very interesting was
that he's like listen it was kind of
released back to the point I just made a
minute ago which is that people who open
vegan restaurants or get involved in
this movement they are you know they
weren't they're not you're not trained
in the way that guys like you and
Sheamus are so he's approaching food and
philippa go in there yes sir from a very
specific culinary point of view and so
he's able to do things that most people
like you know can't other writing people
like yourself and I was like we need
more people like that to be entering
this world because that's really gonna
change people's perspectives on what
this can be like the potential
yeah I mean that's why I call the book
healthy and delicious and I think it's a
chef's perspective that uniquely
prepares us to create foods that are
healthy and delicious because for a long
time healthy meant not delicious and for
a long time delicious meant not healthy
these are mutually exclusive right and
my very first book my tagline is no
longer mutually exclusive and I finally
just said let me call my book health and
delicious because that's really when I'm
trying to convey here common sense
health and delicious right there's no
reason to give one up for the other
especially if you let a chef like me use
my thirty years of experience and
culinary bag of tricks to figure out how
to do that for you and that's and that's
what I do every day I'm sort of in the
lab every day figuring out how to hack
foods or not even hack food just cook
them from the base up to be delicious
and healthy and it's like when I worked
kosher catering for a long time so I got
through college doing kosher catering
people we're gonna track some people
dance I did you did a little dancing -
yeah just never got paid for it
unfortunately I didn't have the right
g-string you know the one that holds the
dollar bills really well I didn't have
didn't have that I'm working on it so
when I did kosher catering me and chef
to chef friends who started taro chips
were working for this caterer and he
would ask us to innovate cuz he was
really interested in pushing the
envelope and moving kosher catering
forward and this is mid-80s right and we
all had worked for jean-georges at la
fête right and we're like it's easy we
just don't have to use just don't use
dairy there's all this other stuff left
when you cut out dairy there's thousands
of choices but you can't see that if
you're not trained to use every
ingredient on the planet and know what
to do with them and how to cook them and
how to prepare them so we were able to
move this caterer from you know the 50s
to current you know trending 1986 food
which at that time was fried vegetable
chips and right and basil oil and that
kind of thing stuff that John George was
innovating and he was amazed you know
and that was like my first lesson and
they're really the parameters don't
matter right if you know how to if you
have the basic skill set parameters are
nothing you know I just did a
competition where all we had were
parameters it's called guy's grocery
games so right
is do everything I can to make it
impossible for you to cook this food but
no matter what he does how to figure out
how to do it right well I think I would
imagine your training in your experience
teaches you what all the rules are and
how to break them in and all the work
around break up yeah but you know what
rule you're breaking when you're
breaking it and why you're breaking it
exactly right and what you hope to get
is as a result and deliciousness is
obviously a number-one priority for me
even though I'm writing I even though I
started writing healthy books the flavor
was still the number one goal right
flavor and then yeah that's the thing so
what is the daily like what is your
daily routine in the kitchen like how
and you said like I'm in my lab and I'm
doing it like what does that look like
so I have a I have a kitchen in New York
City and I exactly and I have a food
delivery service it's called the counted
a diet it's born from my book the pound
the day diet and when I wrote that book
it was the first book that was a like a
real diet book the very strong diet
promise and it promised on the cover of
five pounds five days right that's a
huge promise and to make so of course
publishers want you to prove that you
can accomplish that with your diet so
they asked me to do a clinical trial I
did it with 12 people I put them on the
diet I sent them the food I made the
food that was in the book I created the
calorie restriction and and everything
that needed to happen for them to lose a
pound a day and at the end the we could
of course worked with everybody right do
I say of course now cuz that was six
years ago I didn't know what was gonna
work when I wrote the book but I ended
up proving that you could you could
create a calorie deficit of 3,500
per day and you'd lose weight and then
those people said we don't stop don't we
know that you know it's over but we love
this this is amazing it's life-changing
and I still have some of those clients
so every day I'm innovating new products
new foods for my clients and delivering
six to eight meals a day that helped
them achieve their health health goals
for some people it's losing weight for
some people it's reversing diabetes
reversing heart disease metabolic
syndrome all kinds of things that's so
holy
in the lab working eyes dishes and
everyone gets a custom plan because if
you don't like the food you're not going
to eat it so even though I'm cutting
calories and carbs wrecking and removing
sugars and you know making carb empty
calorie carb dishes protein heavy so so
that people can lose weight
they have to be delicious right so I'm
basically in an RD environment every day
it's unique I don't know that there's
anybody else with your skill set who's
approaching food from a health
perspective in the way yeah we're
frightened to death to do it there are
being made fun of embraced by the
community of chefs he's got a very
powerful message that no consistent with
your own yeah for sure for sure and he's
doing in restaurants and he's and
there's acceptance and it gives me
actually a lot of hope because I've been
looking for the next opportunity to
maybe get back in the restaurant
business and I keep telling people who
come to me and ask what are you gonna do
I'm like you know if I do what I did in
the 90s it's been done what I'm really
passionate about is healthy and no one's
ready for it but you know I think people
are finally ready people are getting
ready for it yeah I think people are
getting ready for it and just walking
around New York City and seeing the
proliferation of you know plant-based
focused restaurants it's kind of amazing
like I just love going there and every
time I go there's new places all over
the place and you know new organic fresh
pressed juice but it is is like
everywhere they're right all within
walking distance so you know maybe it's
not as penetrated into you know certain
areas of America as it could be there's
still tons of we're sure to be shot
we're gonna get into kind of what that
work looks like and and and some of the
things that you're doing in that space
but but in terms of New York City come
on dude it's time right it's W so I'm
excited to see you you know I'm its
timing it's the right I know it's the
right people all the art nerves and all
that kind of stuff but I think the work
I think the world would be excited if
you if you could figure that out well
I'd like to like to think I can agree
with you on that I think the issue for
me is how to make it commercial
and and broad enough so that a lot of
people can participate in it for some
reason that's always the expectation of
me from others yeah I'm very happy doing
something super small and you know
making it available to a very tiny you
know population but it that's not
interesting to other people you know
investors and and big restaurant chains
you know obviously they want they want
stuff that they can scale well it's a
conundrum for you because as somebody
who I mean look you're a legitimate
celebrity you have a very high profile
and that gives you the power to
communicate with a massive number of
people and if you're in the kitchen
you're focusing on serving a very you
know just a select small number of
people I think that aspect of what you
do and who you are is important but
trying to figure out how you balance
those two ways of kind of you know
serving people with your talents is a
tricky equation to solve seems that way
it seems like it's been tricky I'm very
happy doing my small client in my
private client business and you know
definitely changing lives there we've
had people lose a hundred pounds get off
you know loads of Medicine
out of 72 years old that don't no longer
need their diabetes medicine one client
his blood pressure dropped so so fast
that his doctor couldn't titrate his
medicine quick enough to keep up with it
uh-huh and so he ended up passing out
and he was over medicated he thought it
was the food he thought oh you were not
feeding me enough food you're not giving
me I was like no you you're getting 100
grams of protein you're getting this
amount of healthy fats this matter I
know the macro nutrition down I am have
I have every client's mechanism
memorized down to phytonutrients
sometimes and like no you should check
with your doctor you probably don't need
to take that medicine anymore and lo and
behold he checked with the doctors guys
like you don't need this anymore and you
know I'm getting goose bumps thinking
about it was 90 days after he started
that's crazy I I and there's so many
stories like that if people go to their
doctor and their doctors like what are
you doing I've never seen this bread
exactly it's happening like this is a
miracle you know and they can't even
believe that this is actually occurring
for doctors for doctors there unless you
work with an indoor
Dodge's out there but like yeah there's
a there's a big curve there I think that
needs to be yeah that needs to be
addressed of some big fan of doctors
I've been relying on them take care of
my parents my whole life and myself but
the ones that are starting to become
integrative medicine doctors and use you
know functional nutrition and food are
the ones who I think are the you know
they're laying the ralphie yeah and
there's they're creating those protocols
around that you're that you're working
on so when you work so you're actually
working with people like on a one-on-one
yes i it's it's more than one on one
it's 24 sits very close some I end up
being their health coach by design this
is a 360 degree fully integrated program
you get a customized menu plan I have
you wear fitbit's and use smart scale so
I'm remotely monitoring how much how
many calories you're burning how many
steps you know what your bar is like
going online like what's he doing and
some people are afraid you know they
don't know how much information their
skills would give me so I would have
used like a wiving scale to give me
their you know BMR you know ID five
percent which is of course the most
important metric for me the body fat
percent because the total weight is
meaningless without no 95 percent so so
I have small data from wearables and
smart scales that allow me to be
predictive and prescriptive with their
menus so if they did a lot of cardio
today I know they need more carbs
tomorrow typically I'm on a lower carb
keto kind of plan for most people
because most people have eaten way too
many carbs in their lives and yeah so um
so that's one part of it and then I'm
available 24/7 for my clients to coach
them and and talk them out of buying a
pound of skittles at CVS at 2:00 a.m.
and that's cool just has hat that's a
true story
yeah so therapist chef like somebody who
would be doing that there's like okay
the doctor handles this and then we
outsource the food to this person or
whatever I'd like to take all of it to
shoulder all of that for people that's a
lot it's you know what it's a lot or not
a lot I'm not sure I am the most
fulfilling I've ever been in my life I
feel like I spent all my
my all those years of my life most of my
life learning how to cook to do this now
I feel like that was the preamble to
this phase of my life because without
those cooking skills I could not do this
as we discussed already without having
the deep background in the culinary
world that I have
I couldn't make these foods so that they
were you know 78% nor 80% less caloric
dense and you know no sugar and it would
be impossible to figure this right yeah
right right right well that's an
interesting arc because I would imagine
when you're immersed in the world of you
know celebrity chef Dom that's a very
fine dining and those plating you know
kind of in certain respects like you
know self involved kind of universe
right and then to be kind of in this
more servitor role like yeah well I
don't know like I want to get into what
that's like but you know then to be kind
of in service to these people who really
you know not only need you know what it
is that you're providing them but whose
lives are being so profoundly affected
by that is like that's another better
than that I'm so grateful for it and you
know it all happened by accident I
didn't you know create a deck one night
and say hey I got a great idea for a
business let me go fund it and let me go
do you know it just happened organically
and the pound of day diet book was the
beginning of that and it's still going
six years later I still have many of the
same clients and they tell their friends
and it's all worked out really well
word-of-mouth what I would love to do
more than anything is to be able to get
this wisdom and know-how in program and
food to the masses because it would
solve so many of our problems you know
I'm sure you've talked you know
extensively about how eating a
plant-based diet would solve the
healthcare care crisis that we have in
the United States and solve the Middle
East peace issues we have the dependence
on foreign oil I mean it's literally the
solution to almost every problem we
talked about on CNN every day in box
yeah checks every box yeah you know it
really does and yes I do environment
climate change I'm you just you just
keep going down lists I don't think
people realize that the tentacles at how
far-reaching they are that the Western
diet is destroying the world in our
lives and creating all these problems
that we
we don't need to and we're exporting it
all over the world my god I've traveled
all over the place I've been in Saudi
Arabia Pakistan like crazy places I've
given talks and I meet with these people
parents whose kids are obese and they're
experiencing these kinds of health
issues you know diabetes obesity heart
disease for the first time in the
history of mankind because you drive
down the street like it's too hot there
are malls all day and right as fast food
outlets and yeah that's what they're
eating and and they're like why is
everyone all of a sudden fad right and
they're like they don't they don't know
how to deal with it right in a way that
we're learning how to deal with it now
and so this is a global issue it has on
the environmental economic front
literally on every front right this is
the source of so many problems if cheap
processed food wasn't in such high
demand we wouldn't have the Monsanto
issue we wouldn't have the pesticide
issue I mean it's it just it boggles the
mind right right in Hugh and I are
thinking we live like this this is the
solution if everyone would just do this
it would be so simple right you've taken
the red pill in the matrix right yes the
blue pill oh the red though I don't know
the right one the right whatever
whatever you took it and then but then
it's but but if you haven't taken it
it's it's difficult to convince yeah
exactly because everybody's got a kind
of a ride on that on there yeah and your
example can only serve so much right now
the example is very strong though we
shouldn't underestimate them but our the
example yeah but I think I think it it
it begs the question of how you
communicate with the world right and and
the way in which like how do you deliver
this message in a way that it can be
received and is palatable and you know
just in reading the the foreword
materials in your new book it's like
you're it's very clear you're speaking
to mainstream America the average person
like look here's the story you know I'm
not telling you this I'm not telling you
that here's a couple things that I've
learned maybe you know broaden your
perspective a little bit like take a
take a baby step here and there's a
trust like if you do this like your
you'll see results and then you're going
to want to take that extra step but
you're not you're not pushing people
you're not judging anyone so I think
it's really important to be conscious
and aware and mindful
all about the words that we choose and
the manner in which we try to spread
this healthy message because it comes
off it can come off as preachy or
judgmental or you know and that's just
that's working at cross-purposes with
what you want to achieve right right
right I mean you want you want to get on
your soapbox and shout as loud as you
can and you'd be and that Evangelic all
but an hour I think you need all those
voices you know every kind of voice but
I think because you have you know this
audience of people that spans you know
every demographic like there's a
responsibility that comes with that like
okay how am I gonna what you know how am
i choosing to communicate with these
people or the desire yeah as much as a
responsibility it's like I I got the red
pill I want to give you the red pill you
know I figured it out this is so cool I
can't believe that you can go from
having the metabolic age of a 68 year
old man when you're 38 to an 18 year old
and that I did that in a year you know I
went from you know seer being seriously
ill and getting serious advisories with
my doctor who have dr. Michael hammer
I'll never forget the day he's like okay
after all these years of you coming in
here and telling me you've got problems
in me telling you you you're a paranoid
and you're healthy and you're young you
finally have problems you're you've got
things to worry about you're gonna be in
big trouble right I know your family
histories of both sides are my gate
right um really what you know I was 40
pounds heavier was all fat
I was you know eating the foie gras
drinking the red wine the living the
life of the chef you know it's a super
indulgent world and but we're eating
organic food from the market right I
went to Union Square market the entire
time it ran Union Pacific we bought the
best ingredients just that turns out
that those are you know typically high
in sugar and the dishes that the
resulting dishes are typically not not
good for you mm-hmm but I think all
across America and the world doctors are
having those kind of conversations with
38 year old men and women or whatever
yeah and it's only the rare individual
that has that lightbulb moment that
wakes up right really fundamentally
changes their relationship with food and
lifestyle right I had that experience
you have that experience but a lot of
people
are you know there's a lot of people who
will just sit well this is genetic I'll
go on these statins I'll try to like do
a little bit better but they don't
really alter their lifestyle that much
so you know what was it what was it with
you like we just scare the [ __ ] out you
so so I remember it so clearly he he he
told me I would have to take three
medications and he gave me the
prescriptions and he also said as a
throwaway of course you can change your
diet and lifestyle and be more active
and eat better and this will all be and
this will all go away I tell all my
clients that but no one ever listens
mm-hmm and I was like oh this will go I
all I heard was this could go away and I
thought I all right what would tell me
about the medicine so there were some
statins and some you know blood pressure
meds that cause all kinds of side
effects and he started to tell me you
know about the side effects and when he
got to you know certain side effects I
was like okay this the sudden death the
depression suicidal thoughts
you know the anal leakage those are all
fine but you know there are some other
ones that I just cannot accept and you
gotta leave it up to your imagination to
fear which one I'm talking about but I
was like at 38 I don't wanna be faced
with infinite that's just mind-boggling
right yeah and I'm like I can change
this let me let me go try to do that I
said give me six months let me try to
change this and I've been working with a
strainer a really nice guy and just
coincidentally right around the in the
same six-month period my chiropractor I
have scoliosis I've been working with a
chiropractor forever asked me to help
him with a charity he said can you help
me with this charity I'm doing it's
called the grand cup I'm not sure yeah
no problem I'm thinking 500 portions of
you know tuna at some you know catering
event where you know a grazing event
where they invite a thousand people so
few months later he's like are you ready
for the triathlon like what was said was
a triathlon like yeah you signed up for
them remember the grand is Cup it's a
triathlon it's a sprint uh-huh I was
like well tell me about that what is
that he's like well you gotta you know
you got a swim bike run I'm like okay
and my trainer who's never done a
triathlon was really big muscly guy not
triathlon right like a runner too yeah
not like you
we were like okay let's do this right so
we started training and we both did it
we fast forward a few months later we
finished last and next to last yeah I
won't tell you who was last news
exercise and we got you know the Athena
group swam by me in the water like I was
standing still you know the this women
over 60 right I'm the pink caps and I
was one of the first waves to go so and
try speak we're talking about waves in
Todd's pond in Greenwich Connecticut
yeah I did I did New York as well I'm
that once women that Hudson River is
enough it's enough get your immunization
shots I did I Titus immunization I got
yeah you have to get a whole battery
shots I I haven't but I've had friends
that have done look don't though it's a
Manhattan Marathon Island so they go all
the way around like 28 miles all the way
around and sure sure sure and I remember
this is when I was living in New York
like early like 89 90 my roommate who
swam with me in college he wanted to do
it and they give you this handbook and
it has all the dangers what it's like
right when you're up in the Harlem River
and you have to get like 20 shots and
all this kind of stuff and apparently
there was some like by the George
Washington Bridge there's some giant
suckhole like yes yes that's right it's
like all this innocent Riptide then he
got like a in fact you get some like
urinary infection afterwards and he he
refused to believe that was because he
spent you know 12 hours like swimming in
that water so yeah only one infection he
was very lucky so luckily for us on the
New York City try it's only 800 meters
and it's downstream and it's very fast
right and you're out of the water in 18
minutes it was the first time I had
mouthwash in my transition you did yeah
and I used the whole bottle yeah and I
couldn't get that taste out of my mouth
anyway try war story so I did my first
triathlon and it was the best day of my
life I got I crossed the finish line it
took me three hours to do a sprint which
is insane obviously as you know and but
it was a happy save like I never had
felt more accomplished and I had a walk
most of the three miles but we finished
we got it done man I got it done right
brownie and competition against yourself
in the triathlon even though it's a team
sport and then of course I fell in love
with the gear and the gears so come
I mean the gears so much on the rabbit
hole with that forever I'm still in that
rabbit hole right yeah yeah how many
grams I can eliminate off my kit today
and and then someone mentioned st. Croix
Ironman st. Croix of 7.7 went to the the
steepest hill in all of triathlon you
know it's 21 percent right the beast I'm
like I have to do that that isn't it for
me before course - gorgeous yeah great
great course the hell is so punishing
you know that have to the half of people
just get off their bike and walk off and
you can barely walk up the hill because
it's you know it's bad yeah so I started
training for that and then at the same
time it seems just like all the forces
of my life were pushing me down this
path the same time my friend Ben
Silverman
he doesn't look far from here actually
producing the Biggest Loser said hey
we'd like you to come on and teach our
contestants how to make healthy food and
look great okay well I'll do that and I
did a few seasons of that and so so
between my chiropractor and the
triathlon and my doctor and Ben and
everyone was pushed me down this path
and I just sold my restaurant and I
really enjoyed being able to take care
of myself again and having the time to
do that because it does require a
certain amount of yeah right especially
transforming from a fat frat boy to a
dude who can do a triathlon
yeah and if you're in the kitchen at the
restaurant that you own till 2:00 a.m.
not doing the triathlon is probably
right
no Seamus Seamus makes it work he gets
out and rides almost every day different
world right now it really is a different
world he do that he makes it a priority
and he's really talented and you know
super talented and he's able to energize
and motivate people and he's telling his
story really well and then people are
believing it you know and the times are
different in 2005 this story was you
know fell on deaf ears when I would tell
people the story they their eyes would
roll back in their head and they'd be
like okay when you gonna get back in the
restaurant biz who cares about this
healthy stuff yeah yeah yeah I could
barely sell my first healthy book they
no one wanted it took two years to sell
I said this is what I learned training
for triathlons that you can transform
all these lovely dishes into healthier
versions of the their former selves and
there's
be delicious in many cases more
delicious right lobster bisque was my
first such an easy sell to me because
there's plenty of people writing books
about you know with healthy healthy diet
cookbooks but there aren't too many
people that have the skill they were
doctors and they find some chef - like
supplement their book with recipes but
that's very different from you know the
world that you're coming from yeah if
that know some usually it's some it's
some Austrians growing their own food
somewhere and I say hippie as a term of
endearment I mean I love I got you they
got that yeah in the 60s they understood
how life should be lived communes
growing their own food organic right
remember that yeah yeah we were we were
very young obviously at the time but my
sister's who's 11 years older than me
was a hippie oh yeah finition and they
if we just continue to live like that
we probably they'd all be in better
shape but I think the world is more
ready for a guy like Sheamus and a guy
like me and he's you know luckily he has
a restaurant where he can offer
indulgent food he still use dairy and
gluten but also offer all these other
foods that a lot of people are
interested in so when someone like you
comes it's not like you know which which
bad choice do I make tonight which is
the list of the bad choices right so
let's track it back yeah let's take our
back to Queens Queens sure yeah so
growing up in the sixties and seventies
and Jamaica Queens the the cultural
center of America yeah it is well in
some ways was incredibly diverse yeah so
Queens is one of the most diverse parts
of the United States as thousands of
nationalities as millions of people I
did grow up where hip hop was born so
I'm pretty proud of that
you know Run DMC's from there 50 cents
from there
lots of Russell Simmons lots of
important figures in hip hop Russell on
podcast yeah cool yeah and he's all
about yeah so what was that like growing
up there it was it was such a delight
I was the Catholic school kid who had
the maroon blazer and the tie that's a
presentation of the holy virgin or
something on and I had a walk through a
very dangerous park that was next to a
methadone clinic mhm
you know so either your your
with meth heads or heroin addicts or I
mean it was like pick your danger which
which one do you do you want to beat you
up today you know druggies the the gangs
it was wild man as well okay I still
can't believe I grew up there yeah
that's I mean it was a center of the
crack epidemic I mean it was wild but
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
right
and I had this wonderful family and my
mom would make this amazing food every
day at home and so you know I'd be out
in this world where we could eat you're
making beef patties and taste great
Chinese food and Japanese food and other
foods from the Caribbean so in terms of
my palate and my world view was very
expanded by the time I was 14 just from
eating stuff in the neighborhood and you
just did you learn how to cut from your
mom yeah of course she's she's no
question the person who helped help me
recognize the cooking was an important
skill and watching her be this wonderful
him being and have this great social
life and always using food to help
facilitate it I mean she used food in
like quite literally to facilitate
social her social life on buses she
would take out food from her purse and
give it to stranger oh yeah Wow I
usually chunks of parmigiano-reggiano
and homemade bread and they were like
you know if they thought she was crazy
but then they would tell me yeah on the
bus perfect strangers moms a hi honey
how are you hungry they would look at
her like mom is it okay to talk to this
crazy lady and you know she was a sweet
old Italian woman so she didn't look
threatening and she'd give me like a
hunk of Parmesan Reggiano out of her bag
I'm not joking and so she made friends I
watched her make friends her whole life
and so what she taught me was the most
important lesson of the hospitality
industry right is that it's the space
between people the magic that occurs in
that space that's what we do for a
living in the hospitality business in
the restaurant business we attempt to
make people happy and enrich to their
day and provide them with some loving
gesture that makes them feel special
rates connection which an we don't cook
that's secondary tertiary to what what
the real job of a person in the
hospitality the hospitality industry is
which is to maybe people feel loved and
happy and
care for and you know old-school Italian
mom from Italy who came here when she
was 30 she was raised on that you know
and that was just natural to her so that
was the most important lesson that I
learned from her and I to the day she
died I learned it from her and she you
know retaught it and we taught and we
taught it with her actions and you have
to it's very important to have that
because if you don't have that a passion
for that you can't do the difficult
stuff which is the cooking and the
learning in this right living way it's
why behind the how right and the what
exact so you got to have that you got to
have that why so when did it's just too
hard without a bigger purpose right it's
just too hard this is too many hours and
too many cuts and burns and scrapes and
falls and you know pitfalls and
successes and failures and and it's too
hard to get the skills we didn't have
YouTube I did you know if I want to
learn how to make ice cream with liquid
nitrogen I couldn't look it up on Google
you guys had girls yeah I had to go to
Spain and were on Adria and beg him to
let me work with him for two years so so
Queens was interesting we lived there
until is about twelve thirteen and then
we moved to Long Island where I went to
I immediately got into cooking very
seriously my first job was in a pizzeria
my second job was in PE and my third was
in a bagel nosh so I was always in food
didn't did you know though early on that
this was gonna be your path at 14 I did
not at eleven yeah at eleven I just
wanted to buy love gun buy kiss right
and that's why there's a great story
with that right like what's the story
with you like wanting to get this album
from kiss or oh you read the story okay
so if assuming your listeners an urn
could be bored to tears by this I'll
tell it so I love gun came out I was a
huge fan of kiss my mother thought they
were literally Devils right so think you
know 50 year old Italian woman 1977 yeah
I remember that we were the same age I
remember that time right now yeah yeah
it was it was like subversive to be like
a kid yeah and I had my room was covered
in kiss posters for like literally on
the ceiling on all four walls I had
played I played kiss albums all day long
Detroit Rock City loud as possible I
would shy the makeup
thought I was losing my mind you know I
wanted to go the concerts I remember
someone took I bought I saved up money
for the first time they appeared a
Madison Square Garden and my ticket
disappeared to this day I think it's my
make sure I didn't go to that concert so
she said I'm not gonna give you money to
buy this record from these Devils you
wanted this record you got to go to work
and make it the money yourself
and I thought that's me I can do that I
can go to work and make my own money
that's so cool
I don't have to beg you for money
anymore so yes so the next day we went
out looking for work we went to Jamaica
Avenue and Queensland
else I haven't you these big avenues
that had million shops and I walked in
and out of every store with her and like
by the tenth stores guy named Sal said
why are you no problem yeah you'll work
here you'll do you know scoop Italian
ice you'll great mozzarella
you'll open Kansas tomato sauce help me
make pizza serve fountain soda at the
counter pay you 50 cents an hour work 60
hours a week right it's like bingo this
is great that's 30 bucks you know and at
that time having a dollar 50 or pocket
was a lot of money so making 30 bucks it
was it was huge so I worked that first
week I made my 30 bucks I bought some
girls by the stones love gun the down in
Jamaica album can't remember though down
in Jamaica that's a pretty women is that
some Jimmy Buffett is it no it's my
clothes though yeah so about three three
records took my mom to Coney Island
which was you know a big deal for us and
had a Chinese food lunch out which was a
big deal for us because we weren't
really allowed to eat out and my dad
thought restaurants for you know you
can't wisely thought restaurants were
not a good place to go get food
especially when we had wonderful food at
home so that started me working in
restaurants and the next summer I worked
in another restaurant and then at 14 I
started working full time after school
mm-hmm and what was there like a light
switch that went off were you like this
is this is gonna be my life or was it
just a slow acclamation to like being in
this world or it just seemed like a fork
it was an absolute moment where I made a
decision so I was on the wrestling team
I wrestled 145 in high school and
I cooked after school I decided I wanted
to not just work weekends and not just
work summers so I was at a place called
a New Hyde Park Inn and you know making
like close to minimum wage back then you
can get away with not paying people
minimum wage and I was working at a
proper restaurant I wasn't just a
pizzeria that they had you know a real
meal service real banquet hall and it
was run by these old-school German dudes
and they made head cheese from scratch
you know stuff like I was learning real
cuisine and there was a guy there who
was at the CIA The Culinary Institute of
America he happened to work there at the
same time and he was always telling me
about it and you know going on and
bragging about being at the CI it was
such a big deal back then to be in the
CIA the Culinary Institute of America it
was the only school of its kind really
at the time there weren't thousands of
cooking schools back then and this was
like the Harvard of cooking schools
impossible to get into I had a wait a
year on a waiting list to get into that
school yeah you still ended up there
when you were yeah you had to be the
youngest person there definitely one of
the youngest he was trying to get in
there when you were 15
I was yeah so I so once I decided so one
day my coach and wrestling said you have
to make a choice you can't cook and
wrestle because you know we workout
before school after school and on the
weekends and that's when I was gonna
work and I try to do both for a few
weeks a few months and I was missing
wrestling practice and I was missing
late for work and it seemed like I
remember it as the same day it was
probably a few days apart but my chef
said you have to make a choice it's got
to be cooking or wrestling you can't do
both and my coach said it's got to be
cooking lesson you can't do both and and
I remember thinking it's gonna be
cooking I'm much more excited by cooking
and so I quit wrestling and that was the
day I decided become a professional cook
it was about 14 and then I started
talking to the guy who was at the CIA
and learning about how to how to enroll
there and getting accepted there and I
learned that you needed you know
documented in 1600 hours of documented
experience you need the recommendation
letters so I started to do all that and
in 1986 I attended the CIA yeah and I
was 16 turning 17 and it was you know
credibly life-altering the discipline
and just the amount of information we
were that was thrown at us was just for
me like heaven had right yeah
and so did you have to leave high school
to do that like how so I didn't have to
drop out what I did is I went to summer
school so I could accelerate ha Wow yeah
so I graduated early in order to get
into the CA earlier so you were
committed I was a hundred percent in
that I should have been committed
actually because I know 1400 should be
working that hard it's insane it's
almost like a crazy like that level of
commitment at that young of an age it's
almost like you're channeling some crazy
past life you know like the amazing like
this is what you may be you've like this
is what you've been doing ever since
that time so yeah you know that's
amazing too I never did anything else
yeah I mean at 14 when you're enjoying
getting our you know arthritic hands
from peeling shrimp under cold water for
many hours a day and burning and cutting
yourself and you want more and you're
asking to work more and like you're
begging them to let you peel onions
you're committed yeah your head yeah and
you walk into a room on my first day I
walked in they were making head cheese
so this imagine a big wooden table with
pigs heads that have just been boiled to
the point where they fall apart being
picked of all their bones and hair and
teeth and wild stuff right put into
terrines as a vegan you're probably yeah
um external and also the vegan audiences
you like their stomachs ER so we've
traveled like this is part of the world
of you know haute cuisine don't learn
when you're in this one year yeah so if
you're 40 oh you walk into that and
you're like cool this is awesome you're
it was meant to be right guys meant to
be so what do you you know for people
that that don't have any familiarity
with like the skill set that you learn
as a result of you know undertaking that
kind of experience like what is it that
you learned that most people don't
understand about what it means to like
be a chef at that level like what is it
because there's so many answers I can
give you I mean I think I think one
important answer that I should offer you
is an understanding of flavor so flavor
is basically science we have flavor
receptors on our palates with papillae
that recognize certain flavors sour salt
sweet bitter
the main four of course umami isn't as a
fifth now when I wrote my book flavor of
the first book I wrote I talked about
how mommy was an emerging you know
concept but now it's established so
learning how to balance those four
flavors in food after preparing food
creating tension and resolution in that
dish so that when people eat your food
they're excited there's tension meaning
lighting like is this gonna work is this
gonna be delicious there's is there
enough sour salt you know just like
sweet and sour food you know how it
creates tension and then when it if it
works well there's a resolution just
like a beautiful piece of music or even
art or anything that's crafted from your
hands you want at least if you're going
to be a chef that's going to give create
dishes that give people pause there's
got to be tension and resolution and
food for it to be interesting if I
didn't have tension and resolution I
would have been a very good craftsman
and made very good solid food but it
wouldn't have enabled me to have a
restaurant where people came to eat my
food right it would or Seamus wouldn't
be able to do what he does because when
you ate that dinner you were blown away
right right yeah he's mastery of the
senses is what enables him to do that so
ultimately after cutting myself a
thousand times and cutting my nails off
and burning myself and you know you know
we when you're learning how to use all
those tools you're hurting yourself a
lot for the first few years and so if
you're willing to go through that you
end up with a set of hand skills that
are incredibly important you understand
how to cut and prepare every ingredient
every piece of meat fish vegetable those
are basic skills a lot of people just
skip nowadays because they saw how to
make the ice cream with liquid nitrogen
on Google right
but those having a deep understanding of
the craft puts you in a place where when
you're challenged to make something that
has no sugar and no empty calorie carbs
and is high in good fat and high in
protein that typically requires sugar
you know how to do it yeah you have this
you can work yeah you can work around it
yeah
okay so when I make pasta today I you
know I'll get plant-based protein and
I'll mix it with fiber I know that
psyllium fiber gels with in contact with
water so I've already got a paste there
and I'll add some protein powder and
I'll create this mixture that when I
dehydrate will become a sheet of pasta
and you'll know you know that it's gonna
have the right consistency and together
exactly flavor palate and all that kind
of stuff yeah that's well or if it
doesn't I'll know what to do right I'll
know that something has to happen for it
to get to that point and I'll keep
working on it until I get to that point
I've got a vegan donut now that I'm very
proud of working on for more than a year
yeah it's one gram sugar it's got seven
grams of protein it's made you know with
five ingredients and I think it has
potential to change the world I mean
it's that's great because I think one
thing that's interesting with the kind
of explosion of interest in in
plant-based eating and vegan cuisine is
that you have the you have the sort of
concomitant explosion of like super
unhealthy vegan foods like they finally
figured out the desserts you know
there's tons of like amazing ice creams
and cupcakes and like that stuff's great
once in a while but you know taste wise
some of it is indistinguishable from the
real thing and you're like well is this
vegan so I'll just eat and it's like
actually there's like a ton sugar you
know it's like just because yeah
made out of plants and not animal
doesn't mean they don't necessarily
gonna be healthy but but I think you
know it gets people to a certain place
but I think it also is you know
redirecting people down the wrong path
for sure so sure the idea of coming up
with a doughnut a vegan doughnut that
actually you know satisfies those you
know the flavor desire and is the
doughnut crazy craving the whole planet
seems to be obsessed with right now I
know to figure that out like there's the
key like you're gonna unlock the
universe I mean this is a doughnut that
has a nutritional profile that you could
that you could live on this now you
could eat this donut all day long and
you'll get enough fat carbs and protein
in perfect balance you know what dummy
what donut does hurry up with that no
I've got it done I need to get to the
next step I have to send you some and
yeah
like try those out and then I you know I
glaze it I call them dirt donuts I
glazed it with glaze it with yacon syrup
which is this great I'm sure you're
familiar with it and probably all your
listeners are but for the for people
that come to this podcast because I'm on
it
that aren't aren't already in you're
growing it it's a tuber but it's
originates from Peru and it's a tuber
that produces this syrup that looks a
lot like molasses and it's got a
glycemic index of one one one is almost
the lowest yeah like see me context
right stevia has a glycemic index of
zero and it's a non-nutritive sweeteners
yacon syrup is a neutral sweetener has
calories but these are good calories a
really good color so how do you get a
vegan donut to look and feel like a
glazed donut you use you know very
popular in the raw vegan world the yacon
syrup or coconut nectar raw raw of
course a really big fan of raw products
and then I top it with goji berries and
pistachios and all this wonderful stuff
in the world yeah exactly yeah it should
be it should hopefully end up being the
healthiest doughnut ever created but I
love taking the in everyone's favorite
top 10 list junk foods and just flipping
them into something that's actually good
for you you know and I think that's what
chefs like Seamus and I need to be doing
just to prove to people it's healthy and
delicious you can live on this you
should live on this there's no reason
for you to to go to Krispy Kreme and
have ten of those donuts yeah cool man
so so you complete your tenure at CIA
and then you go off and you're in France
yes after graduating yeah work with
Dominic's SEO for two years had it
worked in an American burger joint to
pay my bills yeah yeah I also didn't
have a visa that's a whole other story
but so I mean when you were in Paris
yeah so you were your birthday has this
Charlie's I'm talking about they like
yeah the polarity of those two right
yeah Avenue Raymond wants you it had
Western swinging doors that was the
entrance of the restaurant in Paris I
went there to work with great French
chefs Joel Robuchon one of my heroes at
the time who I got to meet and actually
work with a little bit because my chef
worked for him
you know fulfilling a lifelong dream of
working with the great European chefs
which is what you had to do back then in
the early 80s you had to do that because
we didn't have the the amount of great
chefs that we do now in America now you
can go to any town just about anywhere
and there's probably gonna be a pretty
good chef cooking really good food but
back then you had to travel and get your
creds right those are your creds and
going to Europe was an important credit
so I ended up working at cactus
Charlie's to make my 6000 franc minimum
wage 6,000 francs a month and and I work
for free for Dominic's SEO on them yeah
and what did you you know what do you
learn to work underneath you know a guy
like that you mostly shut your mouth and
do a lot of TV looking and observing and
yeah doing what you're told I mean
there's those days the rules were
absolute there there was a king and you
were a subject and and you know what I
was totally fine with that because the
education that it was I was given as a
result of willing being a willing
participant in that ridiculous scenario
was so valuable and and hard to obtain
otherwise impossible to obtain otherwise
now again of course you can you can
learn these things on Google and YouTube
and you don't have to go through that
torture but um differently something
about going through that that you know
when you burn in that flame you're
coming out the other side like pretty
well fortified for anything that you
come to use a game of Thrones reference
yeah when you come out the unburnt and
learn the superpowers because part of
what we do is dealing with you know
complete chaos and having a stomach for
adversity is a really important skill
and and character trait if you're in the
restaurant business and you can't figure
out how to jump over hurdle after hurdle
after hurdle you're done you're you're
dead on day one well also I would have
met even though it is a you know it's a
Kingdom and there's a king like there's
still it's still contingent upon you
know how how developed your people
skills are right because if you can't
run your team in a functional way you're
in trouble right so you can be as
talented as anybody with what you put
together on that plate but
you don't know how to communicate and
like work with others like yeah it's not
gonna last very long right so yeah it's
it's interesting that you say that's
very true today back then the way the
form of communication that was most
prevalent was simply example so you you
watched you had a watch you had a watch
we're not allowed to ask questions
really you have to learn from watching
and trying and if you messed up you'd
you'd hear about it but if you did right
you wouldn't hear a word and that was
not being spoken to or yelled at was a
great thing
silence was perfect yeah no news is good
news back in those days now there's a
lot of catering and you know catering to
people's needs and you know the
traditional mentor-mentee relationships
where you're nurturing and teaching and
hand-holding people through the
processes but back then just wasn't
enough time and you just had a quietly
observed for years right you know for
years and if you could when your time
came up and the guy who did the fish
station was sick and they asked you to
step in if you could do it you're golden
if you couldn't and you weren't watching
this without goodbye good luck go
elsewhere or stay in the dish room keep
peeling carrots or whatever is your
doing but there's something beautiful
about that process and I think you're
you're about to speak to that
understanding what it takes to learn
these deeply important skills and that
sacrifice is a part of it but the
rewards are so worth it you know because
these are skills that are so deeply
ingrained now you know I can I can
access them so easily and it helps me
every day you know and I see people who
don't have the skill didn't do this
process struggle to you know it and come
to people like me and Seamus and say why
do you do these things and I think it's
gonna be I think what's gonna finally
make what you do and I do mainstream is
enough chefs and medical doctors getting
into the business and and collaborating
to create medically sound and I'm
talking about real real integrative
medicine not in traditional Western
medicine medically sound
examples of food that will reverse the
the problems and the disease that we
developed from the Western diet chefs
and doctors I think yeah I think there
would be I feel like there needs to be
bridges built the chose two worlds like
don't they live in they live in
different universes right these people
are not talking less and less by the way
yeah but I think their work with an
integrative doctor for that I used with
my clients and you know he's really into
the food and you know the mark hymens of
the world are out there now and rankle
it and let men of course yeah - Jeffrey
Morrison and you know they're starting
to bring the world these worlds together
and I think that's gonna be super
important because I think as a chef if
you you need the credibility if someone
in them in medicine almost did convince
the person who's dabbling in healthy
well its embody I don't think you know
the doctor needs the guy who knows how
to make this stuff amazing you know so
these two things can mutually benefit
from feeling more deeply embedded with
each for sure thing yeah well let's talk
a little bit about you know I want yeah
what have you been wanting to talk about
yeah I mean I have your wife I know she
just she's here so wait a meet her I saw
her was she a few months ago she'll be
delighted
yeah she's super excited and she's
finishing up Jesus she well our first
book was plant power the plant power way
but she's just delivering the plant
power Italia so she's doing an Italian
plant-based cookbook so I'm sure amazing
that's Mediterranean yeah cuz you know
they've been doing this for a long time
right yeah of course well wow that was
our first one
these are children so uh-huh Wow some of
them are hanging around here some of
them are school I don't know where they
are
yeah forty nice job my friend our nephew
lives and they're also all vegan how to
early everybody's vegan amazing that's a
rule is that it's not really the rule it
just that's how it evolved like did you
have to at some point like advocate for
your position when they got old enough
to learn that they could argue with you
it wasn't really kind of like that it
was more like well like you like I was
fifty pounds overweight no it was stuff
in my face with with fast food and yeah
Julie wasn't totally plant-based but she
was super healthy and her relationship
with food isn't Chuck and then I made my
changes and I went totally plant-based
and then Julie kind of got on board with
that over time and then we just we never
made an announcement it was just we got
rid of all the junk in our house and
started replacing it with healthy stuff
and Julie's an amazing cook is that
prior to so them coming to the planet
well well our two older boys are 21 and
22 so they you know they had been eating
and they're dead like they're my stepson
so they're they would go to their dad's
house and eat differently and then they
would come here and we would eat
plant-based but we wouldn't say like you
can't whatever like she'd Julie just
made amazing food and then over time
that's just what they preferred and then
before they knew it like oh I guess this
is how we're eating you know and
indoctrination like when they go to
their friend's house it's not like oh
you can't eat this like eat whatever you
want like weari this is way we're eating
here right and just over time it just
became that's clear to them most of the
better path that's better and I feel
better and I go for it and that's just
kind of how it's happened and every kid
has have their own different version of
that story and yeah some have taken
longer or whatever and have their you
know different kinds of you know
different kind of learning curve but
that's that's what we do so you're not
having those moments where they're
bugging you to take you take me to
McDonald no never like our to our girls
who are 13 and 10 I've never had
McDonald's great ever have Nicole so
yeah they've been they've Envy in their
their whole lives circle
yeah and that I mean they've had you
know they've gone to a birthday party
and had cake or pizza it's not like that
but it's just basically this is the
lifestyle that we that we lead and
they're yeah totally on board I know
they advocates now too
do they realize they're in a position to
be advocates and yeah I think that's
possible of starting to come along with
our 13 year old I mean they go to the
school around the corner called Muse and
it's plant based oh that's really James
Cameron and Julia Cameron Julia not
Julia Cameron Suzie James's wife started
it with her sister Rebecca and you know
their ardent plant-based
environmentalist or whatever so that's
plant-based launched made at the school
amazing food
and so basically this is my every kid
that goes it that's what that's the way
it is and so and they teach
environmentalism and so they're you know
they're they're being you know kind of
educated from that perspective yeah and
I think that naturally will instill in
them as they age like a sense of it you
know advocacy then having Bob see you
picked the school and that was a very
wise choice so having that obviously
makes it makes it much easier because
that's isn't that the big problem when
kids start going to school and seeing
other things of course yeah well school
is a disaster and that's one thing I
want to talk about because you know a
lot of what you do is in this advocacy
space sure I mean you know dealing with
you know how can we get our kids healthy
healthier like how can we change the
food paradigm in schools and and how can
we address this massive problem of food
deserts and unhealthy foods in you know
the socioeconomically challenged you
know communities that that you know
proliferate across the world I mean
under from Jamaica like which so you
know there's a lot of people that I
would imagine you see on a daily basis
and they're getting their food from
bodegas and that's pretty much it right
and this is like driving a bodega still
sell plant them right so you got and
they so lots of detail just Crowley due
to their liquor stores basically a lot
of I mean calling it I'm just saying
like the corner 7-eleven got you know I
definitely don't system where you know
farm subsidies are you know keep the
cost low on these snack foods rents
processed foods and sodas and fast food
and the like and when you're tight on a
budget and you got a bunch of kids like
you're gonna eat the cheapest thing so
you're gonna be the quickest to be the
most unhealthy you're gonna have a
highest incidence of these chronic
lifestyle illnesses and it's it's a
vicious cycle that is further driving
the economic divide between the haves
and the have-nots and at the core of
this the very center of this is food
mm-hmm right and so I know you've done a
lot of work in this space like how do
you think about this yeah so I
definitely am spending a lot of my time
advocating for better food policies in
schools with several charities health
core wellness in schools feeding America
food
charity and charitable work has always
been a part of my life from my again my
mom's example at the Rosary Society my
Catholic school and fundraising that she
participated and it was always something
we did so it wasn't something I got into
as an adult I've always thought that
this is a this is a part of a human's
life like doing charitable work and
about 15 years ago I had to sort of pick
because as a chef you're asked to do
lots of charitable work and it's it's an
easy ask right you donate a dinner you
donate something you can you can help
people raise money very easily very
quickly and it's fun you know people get
to experience a dinner cooked by Chef or
will come into a restaurant or whatever
so and we're giving by nature right
we're chefs we could we feed people we
want to give everything away we none of
us want to charge we we'd give
everything away if we could in a
heartbeat
and many of us do much of the sugar none
of our partners so I don't know when you
went to Sheamus place did he give you 15
things you didn't order probably of
course that's how we are remember
whether he charged me he might have not
even like he might have not even though
I'm sure either comped you or comped
half the bill or something
I'm sure hopefully his partner's not
listening uh but so I had to make a
choice in my choices were to focus on
food insecurity and advocacy and
education regarding food and so that's
how I ended up really laser focused on
health core which is dr. Oz's foundation
where they bring healthy to high school
students and wellness in the schools
who's partnered with a do-e of New York
City which took them ten years to do and
now that they've partnered up there in
30 in front of 30,000 kids a day I think
in New York City and they're now in like
five states and they're growing very
quickly Seamus is involved with them as
well
it's what they do it's very very um
seems innocent but super Sneaky they
were the deal they made was they would
create the salad bar menu every New York
City school has a salad bar you get one
dollar a day per student and that sounds
like nothing right but the dollar is
actually a lot if you spend it properly
you buy local seasonal food which we can
do in New York City because we do have
eight months of growing and a great
farmers market and so in the salad in
their salad bar they sneak in all this
healthy plant-based food and kids just
like it because kids I'm not stupid
kids see a pear and if you can get them
to try it
they'll recognize that this this fresh
local pear tastes really good and part
of being an ambassador for health core
is visiting schools I visited hundreds
of schools met with thousands of kids I
used to bring my food truck to the
school and they're receptive and they're
into and they got they get this they're
frightened to death that their parents
are gonna die of diabetes you know so
these kids are like the analog might be
you and I and the 70s worried about our
parents smoking I don't know if that was
an issue for you but it was for me and
so I used to hide my dad cigarettes and
put snaps in them so they exploded when
he smoked about movin we did everything
we could to get him to stop smoking now
kids are trying to get their parents to
eat you know less sugar so they're
diabetic syndrome you know the the the
disease and the symptoms aren't
affecting the family as much because we
have serious diabetes type 2 diabetes
yeah your whole family's feeling this
right you're you have symptoms that are
you know basically causing disturbances
in everyday life of course
yeah the ripple effects of that are
unbelievable and you know it's difficult
to change the habits of 55 year old man
or woman who's been doing a certain
thing in a certain way their entire life
but not if I can get them the doughnut
and what you do I'm not saying it's
impossible you and I both change but you
know for a lot of people this is hard
but kids you know they're they're
they're dialed in man they're interested
in sustainability forced and organic
like they they get it it's not a hard
it's not a hard sell and I leave it in
New York City not the west coast where
you're hyper aware of all this and
there's a really big difference by the
way I'm not sure if you're aware of that
but it's it's even though New York City
is a super progressive we're not talking
about this stuff as much as you guys are
and there aren't plant-based schools
just send your children to there is one
in Queens is there I went there and did
a early on of my podcast I forget PS oh
this
forget the Nam brilliant uno first
vegetarian public school in the country
incredible I think I call it vegetarian
but essentially it's plant-based there's
a there's an organization called I'm
forgetting it right now I'll put it in
the show know it's healthy school lunch
for kids in New York healthy I forget
that's amazing name and her name is
escaping me right now but they're doing
amazing work trying to shift the school
lunch you know sort of systemically and
this school they were they had Hanging
Gardens in the in the on the vertical on
the basketball court you have vertical
gardens in the classrooms and in the
library and like it was kind of
integrated in the whole culture well but
that's the outlier you know like that's
the example right we all aspire to that
but we're dealing with bureaucracy I'm
lobbying and you know regulatory policy
and all of these things that are driving
these decisions and there's a lot of
money to be made you know these
contracts from keeping it's awesome the
way it is yeah whatever pretend the
writer is providing that food like
there's there's you know people on the
state and federal legislators that are
trying to make sure that they get that
contract and that contract stays and a
lot of that is [ __ ] food so but our
non-stop blabbering is working mm-hmm
this talking and talking and talking
with people who are not interested is
starting to have an effect people are
starting to see the benefits of a
healthy lifestyle forget about just
plant base but the healthy lifestyle
they're seen in the behavior of their
children they're seeing it in their
co-pays of prescriptions on a monthly
basis you know those are those costs
start to add up after a while
and you know when people tell me I have
a big family I can't afford to feed them
healthy I always say well what does it
cost you when you lose the you know your
top income earner at 50 years old what
does that cost your family over 30 years
it's you have to give them all the costs
to get people to motivate themselves
that like oh well you're gonna pay for
it now you're gonna pay for it later cuz
you're gonna be sick but people are like
yeah well I'll deal with that well
they're paying for it sooner because
type-2 diabetes didn't exists in the
sixties when we were kids that was
extremely rare I think I think was
called early onset right and yeah it's a
disease we essentially recruit we have
denial do not abuse early on
right yeah and it's it's now more and
more prevalent and people are realizing
that you can fix it with food and we've
got guys like dr. oz on TV every day
advocating for this stuff and other
people like him
and I think the message is finally
getting around I think what we need to
do is work on providing people with the
actual food you know like yet get the
how do we need a little sort of all I
mean there is you know kind of preface
this there is a sense or an idea that
you know healthy living wellness you
know like was it started for rich people
yeah it's like an elitist thing you know
you're talking we're talking about
spirulina and cordyceps and crazy you
know it's super expensive superfood
right exactly how can we make just
simple healthy eating
you know predominantly plant-based plant
bait whatever like how can we get people
who really need it the most and can't
afford it access to these things so I
don't know what people are seeing that I
must be missing but when I go to the
farmer's market in New York City they're
taking snap they're they're discounting
oh they take snap they test out every
mark in New York City
they're doubling the dollar sometimes
they're doing offers were every snap
dollars worth $2 and just for the
listener snap is essentially food stamps
exactly yeah it's it's it's Nutrition
Assistance Programs that's a federal
program for people who can't afford to
buy food for their family so they're
making it very very compelling to use
their snap funds at the farmers market
versus the bodega where you would
typically buy a bottle of Fanta right
with your snap money so there are places
and there are opportunities you just
need to hear this stuff from guys like
us or learn about it at the market but
I'm at the market I see a lot of people
from communities that we think of as the
ones that are typically affected and
most by the the notion that healthy is
only for wealthy people and they're
they're buying smart they're buying
smartly they're buying vegetables and
they're coming at the end of the day
sometimes when the farmers are giving
away the food basically because they
don't want to go home with all their
food they have these mone dollar bags at
the end of the day that are like five
ten pounds of greens and tomatoes and
whatever it is that they don't want to
take home
so it's it's a change of routine I think
I don't really believe that a pound of
broccoli is more expensive than a pound
of hot pockets I just if you do the math
in terms of edible product data and this
yeah I mean plant what I love one thing
I love about plant-based foods is that
plants are much less expensive than
meats and I can make these donuts for
little to nothing you know using
chickpea flour right and it's it's
inexpensive stuff so I need someone to
make the case to me that living
healthfully is is only for the wealthy
and more expensive because I just don't
see it
right doesn't make sense does it merits
it doesn't it exists if you're going to
Whole Foods in erawan and like Whole
Foods now everything's cheap at Whole
Foods yeah it's no longer I think you're
right I think Whole Foods helped create
this this notion that that's how you
live a healthy lifestyle you have to go
to Whole Foods but it's just not the
case there are farmers markets in every
city in America and if you live in a
food desert you're probably living in a
desert of every kind so you're probably
driving around a lot you know to go to
work or elsewhere and you're passing
opportunities you know it's really
mindset and learning how how much damage
you're doing to your children if you're
not making the case making a choice to
feed them the healthy foods you're gonna
pay pretty soon it's not gonna be 50
years down the road yeah yeah yeah
exactly it's crazy I think I the stat
that I saw that was by 2030 30% of
Americans are going to be diabetic or
pre-diabetic and I can't remember what
the childhood rates are for that but
childhood one of the bad no it's not
gonna be one of four but yeah there was
like did you see this last weekend New
York Times did a documentary on the
impact of the impact on ultra-processed
foods on Brazil like all these yes I did
it's notably well yeah and you're just
seeing like how it's just wreaking havoc
on this culture yeah you know because
they're who Tarragona being local it's
lo great food that there
mothers or someone at home would have
cooked yeah when Mexico eclipsed to
America as the number one most obese
country that were oh I almost cried
because every time I've been to Mexico
I've eaten the most wonderful local food
I've ever had in my life I mean they
have a cuisine that is so rich and so
delicious and all based on local
ingredients hyper local ingredients you
know there are parts of Mexico that
don't even know about the ingredients
that are in other parts of Mexico the
same is true in Italy
unfortunately Europe is changing you
know I talked about the Mediterranean
diet a lot because it's in my opinion
one of the best examples of a
sustainable 4life diet pattern that
works basically and doesn't leave you
feeling like you're deprived but that's
changing too you know the Spain and and
Italy are starting to the obesity issues
crazy it's even starting to encroach on
blue zones you know where the people
have lived that you know it's like it's
it's a global issue and it's not a small
thing
yeah you know we're talking about and
this is the balance of you know the
well-being of our species
yeah and we're just propelling ourselves
down this path that is just decimating
our health and bleeding our resources we
made it
we acclimate to it as as if it's just a
new normal you know it's like this is
just way the way human beings act and
look and eat now and it's it's not we
need to take a step back and don't
really look at what we're doing and I
think it's you know maybe it's
uncomfortable for you know some people
to have to look in the mirror and and
and hold themselves accountable for
their habits and their behaviors but
this is your life man and you know I
think we all need to take greater
personal responsibility for the choices
that we are making and and to the extent
that the problem seems so daunting and
unsolvable like we're just who am i you
know I'm just a dude you know everybody
votes with their dollar and a dollar
counts and we live in a capitalist
society and if you start buying them you
know almond milk and not dairy like the
economy is gonna shift around that and
we're already seeing that like there's a
lot of a momentum and I'm excited I am
are you optimistic like how do you look
at this like after this hurricane cycle
and the wildfires this year in the
earthquakes
little less optimistic it's like it's
been quite a season but I'm definitely
optimistic because I do see I do see
what I care about in food growing not
shrinking and I do see more I do see and
hear more people talking about it more
people interested in it you know when I
when I pitch these books to publishers
now they want what I what I used to have
a hard time selling they're looking for
that now and when I talk about a vegan
doughnut people are excited you know
it's not like eyes rolled back in their
head anymore and like oh Rocco enough
with your hospital food my chef friends
thought I lost my mind and went off to
make hospital food right that's how they
described what I was doing what do they
think now I have to ask them but I think
based on the number of chef friends who
are now in their 50s and asking me for
help I think that their opinion has
changed a little bit what do you think
about the whole culture of celebrity
chefs as as somebody who's you know walk
through that world so I like there are a
lot of wonderful things that came out of
that movement one chefs have been able
to impact the collective American palate
in positive ways not always positive but
many and mostly I would say positive the
fact that there are farmers markets
everywhere again you know the ones that
disappeared in the 60s that are all back
I think as a result of chefs you know
looking for better local seasonal
ingredients you know the fact that
there's a user flavored Snapple I even
like to take a little credit for because
I was one of the first chefs to use yuzu
in the early 90s so I think we have we
have a voice and people like to listen
to us because we're fun we cook food and
we celebrate and we do it 24/7 and so
I'm glad that we have a voice I don't
think we're celebrities in the sense of
you know real celebrities that go to the
Emmys and do the red carpet and we're
people that are looked at first of all
yours you are celebrity so there's that
but like also there was there was kind
of like I don't know what happened in
the culture but like suddenly whether
it's reality TV or whatever it is like
there was a thing or suddenly like these
chefs who were doing amazing work who
were kind of doing it you know had their
followings and had notoriety in in that
subculture were suddenly you know sort
of foisted on the public and and there
was kind of a
you know a fever around that that I
don't know if it's still like that maybe
it's I've been I mean since the 90s when
is this chef thing gonna end it's gonna
end I think we're part of the permanent
fixture now you know we're part of
American pop culture or culture in
general and that's a good thing because
we're food advocates and we're people
who are charitable and we're people who
like to make people happy so that that's
a really good thing in terms of the
celebrity alone aspect that there isn't
a chef out there who really is known for
being a celebrity they all learned how
to cook at some point most of them and
they either had restaurants so we're
working people you know we're not we're
different we're different than a YouTube
star or you know that that ilk do you
know what I mean yeah and I think it's
great that I think it's great that we
were given an opportunity in the
eighties starting with Wolfgang Puck and
Emeril and to address America as an
audience because we have good things to
say important things to say we're a
positive force you know we got to wrap
it up here how many things I want to
tell you I feel like I just said you
don't have to stop so many things Wow um
no the book yeah I have a new pack yes
yeah go go into it please it's over 200
the official subtitle is over 200 mostly
plant-based recipes for everyday life so
I what I want to do with this book is
not ply you with diet theory not tell
you about the keto diet the
Mediterranean diet the Paleo die the - I
had my readers get it they understand
there's lots of diet theory in lots of
ways - biohack and and you know I break
into the system and get your body to do
crazy things but really what's
sustainable over a long period of time
is just cooking healthy food and I'm
talking about common-sense healthy right
we know that there's too much sugar in
our diet so I don't use any sugar
refined sugars in this book I don't talk
about it in the beginning very much but
I don't use gluten I don't really use
dairy in this book except for I brake
for Parmesan Reggiano
and I find that for most people when
you're making pasta out of like pea
protein you have to have partner it out
and get them to eat it but uh but your
wife's version of Parmesan he's gonna
say you gotta like check that out I deal
with izing that for your next book I do
so the book the book is actually 248
recipes so it's a proper cookbook it's
the first proper cookbook in eight books
and I believe that there is something in
that book for every single person who
wants to cook at home and live a
healthier lifestyle and these are super
simple recipes and every every book
every recipe has a picture which is
super important my readers keep telling
me they want more recipes and more
pictures that's all they they keep
telling me so I'm delivering what you've
been asking me for the pictures of hyper
focused on the food extreme close-ups
it's food porn at its best well there's
there's certainly no shortage of
plant-based recipes in there too and I'm
excited to try them about 90% well yeah
there's a few miss yeah you can you can
throw the baby out with the bathwater I
doubt we'll get you there we'll see what
the next you know what I mean check in
with me in a year man I'm gonna get you
your entire thread clearly but uh but
it's cool man and I appreciate I
appreciate the work you do and it's been
a cool journey to kind of watch from
afar and nice to meet you I think it
would be great to kind of round this out
and and let people go with you know some
some wisdom around trying to help people
like you work with these clients one on
one you're seeing it on the front lines
like people that are struggling with
food and trying to find their way
through it you know somebody's listening
and they're stuck and they're like I
hear at all like I understand it like I
just you know how do I take that first
step what do I do like how do i how do
you know how do i put that that first
foot forward like you know help me throw
me the life yeah so the prequel is the
hard part the prequel is always the hard
part and I talk about this a lot with my
clients getting to the point where
you're making a conscious decision to
change your life right and that's the
struggle once you've made the conscious
decision it's usually fairly nice to be
self-motivated has to be a self driven
thing yeah be an internally you know and
hopefully not always motivated by
something catastrophic your doctor tells
you right unfortunately
that's what happens most of the time but
you know what just give yourself 72
hours and try some of the stuff we're
talking about just you know try my
recipes try your recipes try try you
know making yourself shakes and
smoothies for three days out of you know
full fiber or no juicing you know
blended vegetables and fruits and give
up the gluten and the dairy and the
sugar and tell me how you feel because
you'll feel a difference in about 12
hours and 72 hours you will definitely
feel a difference right and you'll get
to a point where when you add that stuff
back you feel a negative difference you
start to feel really bad
once your body's clean down and detoxed
yeah so where you're you're you're
getting people that connect with how
they feel physically if you're seeing
junk all the time that you acclimate to
that that's your normal right you lose
touch with how you can feel yeah right
so creating that connection so if you're
one of those people that's always tired
and cranky and you're overweight and
your clothes don't fit and you're super
self-conscious and you know you're sick
of that give it a try nothing to lose
you know go to go to negative calorie
diet try my 3 day cleanse it's a cleanse
with food so it's not one of those crazy
juice cleanse read nothing try you know
I know the first 10 pages of plant power
way I'm sure has a great plan just try
it and and and then tweet me and tell me
you don't feel a difference I dare you I
dare you to tell me you don't feel the
difference because you will one
important thing is to drink a lot of
water very important that people don't
realize we need to be our muscle is the
only part of our body that burns
calories and it's not fully hydrated it
doesn't work and so drinking a lot of
water is super important through any of
these processes as you detox water will
keep you sane yes man
Rocko's healthy and delicious yeah comes
out in October 10:17 right well this
here what's that when will this air I
look at the calendar I'll try to I'll
try to orient it around it when it comes
out yeah no worries Ben yeah but
probably around that same time
that'd be great cool man yeah thank you
this is really wonderful yes man
awesome good talking yeah
cool so you can find rock is pretty easy
to find on the internet Rocco DiSpirito
ubiquitous what do you like it
haha all good man you got any triathlons
coming up are you doing still so back
surgery two years ago now Ben yeah yeah
yeah so running is definitely other
question I can bike still but it I have
to refit my bike now and uh-huh yeah you
live in Manhattan yeah you do yeah yeah
so where do you where do you go do you
go up like up across the road you know
yeah I do up and down to the bridge from
I live all the way downtown so Upper
West Side yeah plus out in Long Island
yeah alright nice dude but if you know
one thing it's 90% food right
you know this yeah I think the game is
90% food so if you're eating well you
don't have to you know do a triathlon to
get into shape you don't have to do any
of them it's wonderful to do and
definitely something you should try if
you're into it but you don't have to go
do Barre class and do all these crazy
things if you're if if you're just
eating well because you'll get to 90% of
your goals with a change in diet and a
profound change in diet for me and if
you are doing all of those things and
you're not paying attention to how
you're eating it's not gonna work you're
gonna end up one of those people like my
clients who say I work out all the time
I can't lose weight it's cuz you got you
can't out train a bad diet I just can't
good talking you man yeah cool peace
Lance
you